cette nuit nous passons de l'heure d'été
à l'heure d'hiver au faites où est-ce
qu'on avance ou on recule l'heure on va
la reculer ou l'avancer je ne sais pas
du tout c'est l'heure du ver donc on
avance d'un heure on avance toujours on
va perdre une heure de sommeil c'est
tout ce que je vois nous la retardons
pas nous la remettons en place
euh on va retarder demain on va dormir
une heure de plus ça va être bien
agréable la recule nous l'avançons si
vous pouveiez le faire pour le supprimer
cette affaire parce que les personnes
âgées on subissent énormément les
conséquences et surtout les enfants leur
c'est une division artificielle du temps
alors je crois que tout le monde devrait
s'en fiche puisque il y a des gens qui
protestent parce que finalement les
seuls qui pourraent être gênés c'est les
acuponcteurs ils vont être obligés s'ils
ont les aiguilles plantées à cette
heureel de les changer les avancer ou
les reculer il y a que ces gens-l qui
peuvent protester